efforts to ban flavored east cigarettes
while understandable will cause more
harm than good
some vapors will simply resume smoking
deadly cigarettes others will seek out
dangerous counterfeit faves these
cigarettes are considerably safer than
cigarettes and flavors are a powerful
incentive for effective use by adults
these cigarettes deliver nicotine as an
aerosol while cigarettes burn tobacco
it's the smoke from burning tobacco not
the nicotine that contains carcinogenic
tar now we don't know the health effects
of years of inhaling e-cigarette aerosol
researchers will need to follow vapors
for many years and this uncertainty is
why non-smokers should not start to vape
one of the biggest concerns about teens
that vaping leads to more teen smoking
has not happened so the FDA should not
ban flavors other steps can be taken to
reduce teen access to e-cigarettes
meanwhile we need to protect safer
alternatives to cigarettes for those who
already vape and the 35 million American
smokers who have yet to quit what do you
think should the u.s. ban flavored
e-cigarettes let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI